all right good afternoon everybody
Welcome to the retirement
commission four six eight nine 10 11 all
right we do have a a quum so our first
item is to review the minutes the
previous
meeting which
approve okay any discussion Corrections
or
comments seeing none those in favor I
opposed all right thank you very
much so our
next item is to review the Actuarial
cost estimates Mr Carlin don't get
comfortable
does everyone on the commission have a
copy went about in the mail this email
this
morning
yeah yes there's a new one this
morning okay there I believe there's
some hard copies on the table
thank
okay uh thank you madam chair um for the
record Marty Carlin with the New
Hampshire retirement system three of the
grid uh that you should all be familiar
with by now uh the two two rows
highlighted in Gray at the top of the
page and just as a
refresher what this does is it takes a
previous proposal that was analyzed that
called for uh the multiplier for all
group two members in tier B and tier c
as well as future hires to uh change to
a 2.5% multiplier for every year worked
after attainment of 20 years so last
week the commission asked if GRS could
turn around uh analysis with that two
and a half multiplier kicking in at 15
years of service after completing 15
years and after 10 years so those are
the two um proposals at the top of the
page um you know there's an unfunded
liability uh component to both and they
um you know obviously the 10 year is is
larger than the um uh 15-year and then
in column three it shows uh first at the
top of that column the rate
increase um over you know in addition to
the current rates um with no prefunding
by the state for the unfunded or
anything else um would raise the um
percentages by about 1.35 to 1.4% of pay
uh on the employer rates um with uh pre
prefunding an appropriation from the
state for the unfunded liability uh the
the second set of numbers there uh 0 6
and 63 would be the percentage increase
which is about 3.3 million a year spread
out across the employers proportionately
based on the size of their uh Public
Safety payroll Ro um similarly in the
next column uh which is the 10-year it
shows a higher unfunded um a higher
um membership uh member uh employer rate
increase um you know and with and
without unfunded liability so those are
those are basically how those proposals
would lay out and again this would
impact not only group two tier B
existing tierc members in future
hires thank you so if I understand you
correctly it would be 44 million in
fiscal year 26
to um deal with the current employees or
54 million to deal with the the current
employees plus all future hires is that
correct yeah you're talking about the
SEC second row The 10e Proposal yeah
yeah so so the unfunded if if that was
appropriated uh you know by from the
state the increase to employer rates for
the ongoing future costs of this change
would be um 0.95 or 0 94% of pay um now
would increase beginning in fiscal year
26 the contribution rates uh collected
from participating employers of group
two people by 5.1 million a
year and that that's that's not a
one-year cost that's you know because
this is an open-ended everybody who's
coming into the system there there will
be a normal cost associated with it
going forward that could moderate over
time based on other demographic changes
but this one you can't pay in advance on
because it's
open-ended okay thank you very much does
anyone have a question Senator
Susi but that could be mitigated by the
ongoing reduction of rates as we pay off
the unfunded liability correct yeah yeah
so it mean the rates could even out even
with yeah the you know the the the rates
change every two years um you know the
statutory you know the ACT crunches the
numbers and comes back with new rates so
depending on how investment experience
demographic experience happened
certainly the rates could fluctuate um
you know over twoyear periods ultimately
once the bulk of the unfunded is paid
off in in the end of the 2030s you know
we're going to see a fairly large cliff
in the rates at that point yeah followup
question follow and then just going back
to the discussion we had last week the
number of
employees um for the tier B what is
identified as tier B that number is from
last year correct correct so that number
may have declined a bit since then yeah
I we we expect to get some final
headcount numbers and things you know
broken out by the the tiers from the
actuary fairly soon this month but um
you know um but yet but as PRI our prior
conversation yeah that it's going to be
less than 1732 because people have in
that tier have left service either
through retirement or we choosing to
move on over the past year and and as
the number shrinks there's you know
there's more of an unfunded impact for
that tier because they have more years
in the system already so you know these
these numbers again should be thought of
as sort of a you know the ceiling for
numbers and it may ultimately um have
less pressure on the rates by an
indeterminable amount not you I can't
say it's going to be a lot it could be
next to nothing or it could be no
disable but yeah thank
you other questions Senator Greg I just
want to make it
clear I just want to make it clear for
people uh whether the 3.3 is an annual
cost an estimate made an annual cost or
is that a cost over a period of time and
I believe it is an annual cost yeah that
that's an annual cost basically when we
talk about the percentages in an
employer contribution rate it's a
percentage of pensionable salary okay so
um based on the payroll projections for
what fiscal 26 is going to be uh for the
police and fire the you know increase of
you know 0.95% of pay and 0.9 for is
about 3 million so as payroll grows over
time you know the actual dollar amounts
would be likely to Rise um you know but
is a percentage of the the total pool
you know the you know the the percentage
of pay shouldn't change follow up follow
up so if I look at the 10-year cost I've
got the 30 and I'm going to use the 15
uh year one I would have the
36.3 Y and then if I was getting all the
way to
2036 I would have an additional 33
million so for a total cost
of uh 33 plus 36 get me to 69 million it
for for like you know back of the
envelope math yes I mean you you would
if you wanted to get a bigger slightly
bigger envelope you you would just
increase that 3.3 by the the payroll
growth assumption which is like a
2.75% a year so there there's a there's
a nominal increase in that 3.3 but
multiplying it by 10 and you know it's
it's in that range I'm I'm just trying
to give everyone a you know a sense of
what it looks like for a 10year period
yes yeah thank
you Senator Bradley uh thank you madam
chair so um Marty what is the 3.3
million the normal cost that would be
projected in rates represent as a
percentage of the overall employer cost
for um tier B and well the group two
cost the overall employer
costs okay um the employers are
currently paying I think a little bit
more than 600 million a year in total
for all four member groups so this you
know as as a percentage of total
employer contributions you know 3.3 out
of over 600 is that like a okay five or
5% um yeah 0 five so yeah so so that's
that's the uh you know that's that's the
in context that's the the additional
amount okay thank you and that's
proportional too so a larger Community
with more with a higher payroll for
group two is going to pay more dollars
than a smaller Community with little or
none but they'd have more employees they
yeah just it's all based on payroll size
okay any other questions from the
commission Mr
real thank you madam chair thank you
Marty um I just want to uh clarify a
question I think Senator Susi asked
um employer rates are on schedule to
decline as we pay off the unfunded
liability is that correct
um for through
2039 you know if all assumptions are met
which we all know that isn't really
possible in the real world with
everything going on um they should be
relatively within the same range as they
are now for the next 15 years and when
that liability is is um exercised and
off the books in 2039 it'll have a more
steep drop then but you know if to the
extent that we um have investment
performance you know better than
expected that's going to lower the rates
you know over the next 10 or 15 years uh
that that's what happened with the rates
in effect now the 2425 rates the
investment performance and the F prior
five years lowered them from what they
were the the two years before so there's
going to be variability in the rates to
some extent they could go up they could
go down but the Actuarial goal is to
keep them relatively stable you know and
then anything any good news is only
going to lower them and
then have the uh
the rate of return have they over longer
periods of time have they exceeded the
assumed rates um you know we we just
posted um although another New Hampshire
media picked it up we just posted our 23
investment returns uh earlier this week
and I believe the the the fiveyear
average was um
7% um and I think the 10 was
7.6 um and you know our right now we're
assuming six and 3/4 so that that that's
positive news that's what you you would
consider the overage above your assume
rate of return uh is an Actuarial gain
and that that extra money that comes in
goes straight to lowering the unfunded
and that's going to lower the rates so
um you know as they say past performance
isn't a guarantee but um we're happy
with the the longer term you know five
you know it was 8 8.2% this year and
then the five and 10 were favorable as
well yes the we set the the rates every
two years by calculating all the changes
and that difference is laid on top of
the current rate whether it's plus or
minus so we're hoping hoping to have it
be minus more often than
not
okay anyone else
thank you Mr
Carlin okay Senator
Susy thank you madam chair um at this
time I'd like to make a motion to accept
the second shaded plan which is
identified as the gray 2.5 multiplier at
10 years and if I could speak to my
motion uh please thank you
um I think the creation of this
commission although the language is
Broad in scope looking at a number of
retirement issues the creation really
occurred because we were unable to
quickly enough
ascertain um a modified version of the
language in houseo 436 dealing with the
multiplier since that time we as today
have gotten a series of numbers to to
better quantify exactly the actions the
legislature is taking and the concerns
I've heard expressed about previous
Plans offered are that they're too
narrow in scope they only impact a small
number this plan does not and they cost
even more we were talking about upwards
of 80 million I think the beauty of this
plan is that it satisfies the concerns
that people came in with it accomplishes
what had always been the intention which
is to come up with a way to retain
employees um because that's one of our
our biggest challenges right now is
retaining and attracting new employees
and I think this
plan strives to hit the right balance
and does actually hit the right balance
in the benefit portion and also the cost
portion um for our group two
members and the only other thing I would
add is we've also done something
previously which I did file the bill on
um the fiveyear vesting which would
impact group one so I I I feel like the
committee has hit a critical point where
we are ready to make recommendations and
for those reasons I would support the
10year okay is there a second
Mr thank you madam chair I would like to
second uh Senator susi's motion uh for
all the reasons that she U stated I'd
like to Echo that i' also like to say
that um you know when we when we started
this process uh well over a year ago and
having these conversations about how we
can impact Recruitment and Retention in
the state there was a lot of productive
dialogue um obviously we we stalled out
but when we developed this commission we
all came in with the same uh goal in
mind and that was to to fix uh a
recruitment and retention issue that we
all agreed that we have in the State uh
firefighters police officers state
troopers Corrections parole um there was
no debate that we had a recruitment and
retention problem the debate was on how
we fix it and um you know there's plenty
of data and plenty um of research to be
done that shows that retirement is one
of the number one um players in keeping
qualified Personnel on the line and
that's why we're here today and I think
um you know this this proposal may not
be everything that that the employees
wanted it may not be everything that the
state wanted but I think that to some
degree uh a compromise means everybody
needs to walk away um feeling as though
they got something that is impactful U
but also a sense of of feeling a little
bit uncomfortable um and that's what a
negotiation is and I appreciate
everybody coming together and being
willing to do this Senator gray we heard
you um and your remarks and that you
wanted to impact more than uh the 1700
folks in the sliding scale um we heard
you loud and clear we um are are fine
with with agreeing to that um under this
proposal and Senator Bradley we know
that you needed the cost to come down
and and as you mentioned last week week
uh this this number or the number very
similar to this one uh was getting
closer and closer to the number that you
were comfortable with so I think we've
uh made a fine negotiation here and I
support that thank
you all right thank you any you Senator
greay
um I would have been very happy to
support and even second the motion if we
were doing the 15-year
plan um taking it down to to 2.5 at the
10e um becomes a problem for me okay uh
the reason I was happy with the 15-year
plan it would have been like halfway
through their career okay figuring that
they would work 30 years you know at 15
years halfway through then we boost
their rate from the two to the
2.5 um the cost and again when I asked
the questions before I looked at
basically 10-year cost okay and since
the rates don't adjust until 26 you're
not going to see either that 3 million
or the five million you know reflected
in rates until that time but when you
take that into consideration for that 10
years from 26 to
36 um that is a significant number and
that when you look at it uh over the two
different plans that's that's just under
$40 million the 37.6 I think is if I'm
looking in the right place on my
scribble sheet here um
and it's you know given the economy that
we're in given the other obligations
that we're going to have um that's why I
would be more comfortable at the 15-year
Point uh with the 36.3 million plus the
3.3 thank you
anyone
else Senator
Bradley um thank you very
much so I find myself in
agreement um on a principal basis with
Senator Susi Mr reel and Senator gray
because um these two versions actually
do address retention and Group C and if
we're going to deal with retention we
have to address Group
C so as I said last week
um when the analysis of my Amendment
which was just Group B came in at $43
million um that was getting to the range
of what I thought was
affordable okay so I think
um
really
is more than the affordability index
that I'm willing to um go at this point
and so just looking and and I want to
tell you why just looking at the which
we didn't have last week the final
numbers for October they were they were
better than
anticipated we have a general fund
surplus of $58 million so we would
basically use 96% of the existing
Surplus to fund
The Upfront cost of this
benefit I think that's a bridge too far
I'm sorry to say it but that's what I
think and here's why I think that
so what Senator gray and I because we're
both on the fiscal committee have access
to and I it's it is a public document
and you can find it um on Justice brc's
website for the
YDC um settlement process or Mr Kane can
get it to anybody it's a public
document
so right now as of the end of the third
quarter 180 claims have been filed by
the YDC about $13 million in benefits
have been paid out that's about
$460,000 per claim
the amount of filings are accelerating
that's a good thing that was why the
fund was
created 180 claim claims have been
filed the aggregate amount of money of
the claims filed through quarter 3 is
174.000
million and when I asked the question of
you know this is as of the end of third
quarter so October more claims are
coming
in so I'm just troubled sorry to say it
by
dedicating over 95% of today's
Surplus to this purpose and this purpose
alone when we're looking at this right
in the face knowing that this is a big
issue that has to be dealt
with I don't know what the end results
going to be of the YDC
process I don't know my crystal hat
doesn't say if you know next year is
going to be a good year or bad year
economically a lot of people are
predicting you know a recession with 8%
interest
rates um you know in the home mortgage
our our real estate transfer tax is
already off will business taxes be off
we don't know we don't know and
knowing
um you know what we're facing I think
the more cautious approach is the right
approach and if this motion is rejected
either Senator gray or I will make the
subsequent motion to recommend
legislation at the $36
million uh 15-year range that I think is
achievable and gets through the
process and if there's anything I've
learned over my time in this building is
how do you get to the end of the process
and there's a lot that goes into getting
to
yes and the other thing that I would say
is you can't look at um whether it's $36
million or $55 million in a vacuum we
all voted
for House Bill 1587 which as I recall
cost $ 42.9 million in
2022 so whatever you want to call it
um if we were to
do the 15year and $36 million plus the
42 that we did a couple of years ago
that's almost $80 million for relatively
small group of people now I happen to
think it's worthwhile given our
retention issues given the duress that
our Public Safety folks are
facing but at the at the end of the day
we also have to be cognizant in my
opinion
of you know
this problem that we are facing
that with potentially a thousand claims
out there for YDC and knowing that the
aggregate request for the 180 that have
been filed today is $175 million I think
that the prudent course is to
recommend the 15 years so I'll be voting
against it I hope that motion fails and
then either as I said Senator gray or I
will introduce the subsequent
motion Senator Waters thank you madam
chair
um I do think that you know we know that
whatever vote we take today it's just a
recommendation to the commission and
that the real work will be done uh when
it comes to early next year here and we
will have some more numbers at that
point my own take on this is that while
I really understand the what's hanging
over us with the
YDC money um it just it's a little hard
to think that we're in a situation where
one Injustice seems to
be um and the funding for that is going
to preempt potentially trying to address
another Injustice which is the way I see
what the situation we're in here and it
just the more and more we talk about it
the more awkward it seems to me that
that that is the reason why we can't do
what I think is appropriate policy but
you know dollars are dollars um my own
sense of this um particular addressing
Senator Bradley um on this is
that I do think that the motion that's
made is
aspirational in that it recognizes that
this is a way to address some important
principles to expand a number of people
covered um to go to the 10 years and I
think potentially affordable we will
have a couple three more months of
Revenue um before we have to take votes
on the in committees and on the on the
floor on this so I I I think it would be
I personally it be better for us to pass
this
motion understanding that it is going to
be dependent on what the revenues look
like in order to get support folks like
yourself who who need to support it to
pass it I don't think it would be
inappropriate either to slice and dice
it a little bit we got 15 years what if
we had you know and we got 10 what if we
had 11 years what if we had 12 years I
think there's a way to do that I just
fear that if we reject this motion and
go with the other motion that um it is
it is I think it's going to be very
difficult
to um to see that as as really
addressing the the issues that we were
wared to address thank you madam chair
uh represent o Brian and then Senator
I'll give to Senator Su first you
haven't spoken oh okay well thank you
Madame chair thank you Senator
Susie uh I think Senator Bradley is wise
to bring up you know concerns about the
uh YDC situation that is pending but
however in my time and it's been uh I
don't know 15 years like you madam chair
a long time up here there's always got
to be something that's coming over the
horizon okay it's time to stop that you
know let's focus with what's in front of
us right now and here is the important
thing you take communities such that I
represent in
Nash the state used to pay the 35% now
it's down to nothing and that is born by
the city of Nashville yet now what used
to be the old adage that the job stinks
but the bennies are great now the job
stinks and the Benny stink and we can't
get people to come in and try to get
into this type of position it's fine
when you live in a community that has a
volunteer Force but nashar cannot or
ever even cons seem to have a volunteer
Force because businesses will not allow
people to disappear during the day to go
out to answer some of the alarms and
Medicals and stuff like that my son is
on the fire department his average shift
is almost like 15 runs per shift so
therefore the needs of the city uh are
great and I think I could speak well for
nashal and its mayor they're coming to
the I'm going to support the uh the
second part of the gray proposal the
55.9 million because it will solve the
problem that's directly right in front
of us that's what we need to focus on
again always something on the horizon
that's going to deter our our shiny
objects is going to distract our
attention let's solve one problem at a
time and what's in front of us right now
I think is the uh the second grace
proposal so I support it thank you madam
chair Susy thank you madam chair um I
just want to reiterate what I said
earlier during the budget process we
were literally on the precipice of
adopting a plan we were extremely
extremely close but for more precise
numbers we would have adopted an earlier
version of a plan that would have only
impacted the smaller group so the fact
that we're here talking about a plan
that impacts even more I think is better
so I'm I'm actually glad that we've been
able to move forward with respect to the
Surplus I would say this Senator Bradley
I haven't brought this up at the
commission but I have brought up with
you privately um I think there is apart
from the existing surplus of General
funds another way to fully fund this
plan and I have introduced legislation
confidential at this point um but it
would be legislation to cap the
education trust and there would be more
than sufficient money to fund this
proposal as it could currently stands um
that is something that could at some
point be attached to this proposal as it
moves forward and I hope that it will be
because I think we can fully fund this
and put this issue um aside for the
coming year once we enact this plan so
once again for all those reasons that's
why I do support the tenure Miss
Stacy thank you madam chair so I'm going
to add to Senator Bradley's comments and
just let you to know as a register of
deeds talking about revenues my transfer
tax and L chip revenues are down almost
20% they were down 15% last year this
year I'm looking at over 20% and it's
going to continue I've been in the
business for over 30 years and looking
at the Horizon um we're going to be
struggling uh coming after the first of
the year I know it and we've done it
before and come out of it but our
revenues are Statewide down considerably
thank
you anyone out Mr real oh excuse me Mr
Karen first he's hasn't spoken thank you
madam chair uh one issue which has not
been discussed today and I'm I'm Fair
we're losing sight of it is the impact
upon the property taxpayers all these
proposals do include some additional
increases to the rates which will go
directly to our
taxpayers uh looking back at the number
which Senator Bradley was speaking of of
last meeting which was the $43 million
and I know I know it's not my money so I
can play with the house money at this
point uh you
know if everyone agrees that this needs
to happen for retention my experience
tells me that's not accurate but let's
presume it is for a minute then if you
look at Senator Gray's proposal of 2.5%
multiplier at 20 years that cost is 18.5
million the Delta between
18.5 and the 43 we spoke of at the last
meeting is about 25 million on that one
there's a one-time State appropriation
of 185 and the increase in group two
rates is 1.7 million if we can take the
Delta between the 43 and the 18 which is
about 25 an advanced fund and a separate
Fund in the retirement system to pay for
the contributions of the rates that'll
cover the increase in rates of 14 years
and 14 years bring us almost to the end
of the agreement we all had in which
Municipal rates went through the roof to
pay for all of our trans transgressions
of the past so I I would hope that the
uh commission would consider that
proposal as
well so could you be so your proposal is
to
take the basic Senator Senator Greg
and
um could you explain what your proposal
exactly so I know if you look at the
bottom of the second page which Marty
passed out to us it says of the gray
proposal at 2.5% multiplier at 20 years
right there's a onetime state
appropriation of$ 18.5 million but there
is an impact on the rates of $1.7
million a year if you look at that what
I consider to be the target number of 43
million you spend 18 one time leaves you
a balance of 25 and if you through
legislation put that in a fund to offset
the rate increases of 1.7 that covers
those rate increases for 14 years which
essentially gets us to
2037 and there's a 2-year gap between
then and when the employer rates will
drop because uh our promise will have
been fulfilled to pay off the unfunded
acred
liability ah
okay thank
you anyone
else Mr
martines
thank you madam chair I support this
motion I think it should pass I think
that we should go forward and then there
will be opportunities to find different
ways to fund it but this is not what
we're doing today this is not a meeting
about funding we are coming out with
proposals and for bills that we should
pass to examine what we can do to this
one thing that we don't say enough is
that these workers are the same workers
that had 2% of their contribution
increased with reduced benefits so we
reduce benefits and we increase
contribution and we keep not saying that
enough times right but these are the
same workers and then we recognize that
we made a mistake but when it comes to
the time that we got to do something to
fix it then we want bring why this why
that why this see there's always going
to be enough wise there as to why we
can't do something I say why not we
should TR try this and go forward with
the Motion makes a lot of sense and we
can make it work so I hope you support
that thank you
okay Mr
Fuller yes I just would also like to
lend my support to Senator su's proposal
I think it makes a lot of sense and just
Echo some previous comments as well um
while there's other issues on the
horizon I can certainly respect that we
have one issue in front of us right here
and the fact is is that Senator sui
proposal would I think address that
issue fully so I think if we're looking
at that if addresses the issue we should
be looking at things one one thing at a
time and if we can solve one thing here
now then we should absolutely do it
thank you thank you anyone
else representa
lean thank you madam chair I'll
certainly be supporting rep uh Senator
susi's motion and like to point out that
we've been kicking this issue
for more than a decade on the 1700
employees and the house was willing to
support both Democrats and Republicans
an $80 million proposal just to take
care of the 1700 employees uh I think
this is a good compromise I would have
still been happy with the initial
proposal that was in $436 so the $80
million but this takes it a lot further
out to take care of another
3,200 people that have been affected
um I'd Echo all the positive remarks and
I do sympathize with uh the remarks of U
Senator Bradley as far as the YDC issue
I also serve on fiscal and very
concerned about that situation but I
think this is a time we need to put this
issue behind us especially for those
1700 people that have been affected for
over a decade and again I hope you will
support Senator susi's
motion
any
else all right then um I think we should
take a roll call on this one Mr real
would you call the
roll
no
yes Campo
yes
uh Mr Martin
yes uh Senator Waters
yes Senator gray
no Senator Bradley
no and representative Maguire no
Madam chair passes 8 to
six
okay in that case as we discussed
earlier I'm going to recommend that
representative
prepare to incorporate this
recommendation into house bill 436 which
he is currently holding on
to we will do that we actually have
scheduled a meeting for the division one
members on this coming Tuesday at 900
am. so we'll be discussing this um
motion Amendment at that
time okay that takes care of that
recommendation are there any other
additional plans that somebody wants to
recommend to the
legislature Senator
gray um out of the last uh meeting I was
asked to reduce my recommendation to
writing I think that's been distributed
to everyone it would provide enabling
legislation to allow state employees to
rece pursuant to a collective bargaining
agreement up to a 5% match on their
contributions to the public employees
Deferred Compensation Plan established
in RSA
101-b okay just thank you is there a
second to that
motion yeah second okay moved by Senator
gray seconded by Senator Waters to
submit legislation to allow the the
state to make matching payments to a
Deferred Compensation Plan for its
employees other Employers in the system
already have that ability but the state
doesn't Senator gray and I'll speak to
the motion if I may M chair uh what you
have in front of you is also a sample
legislation when I went to OSS uh to
discuss it with them uh they said that
db7 uh would need to have an additional
sentence put in uh which you see at the
bottom in bold uh and the funding of any
collectively bargaining matched
contribution amount um modification to
uh colon 8 uh which changes the title
except for funding required for the
matching
contribution and then the the last one
uh B would be a new
paragraph um and it would talk to the
state employees
uh being able to do that uh also saying
that the
agencies um should uh look at their
other non-union employees and offer
similar uh
negotiations uh this uh there is no cost
associated with this at this point uh
because it would be something that they
would do through bargaining uh and it
would come through with a as a benefit
cost similar to the way salary increases
come um it would put the state employees
On a par with those local employees who
are already through other means uh able
to do a matching contribution thank you
okay Senator Waters wish to speak
to um I hadn't planned to no
okay anyone Senator Susi just a question
and this is for Senator Greg or perhaps
Mr martines knows what's the current
expiration date of the existing state
employee
contract I'm not 100% sure on that the
expiration of the contract that we have
now I believe it will be in the next
year June 30 uh of next year the
contract that we have now it's enforced
until then
24 so as I understand it this would not
apply until the next negotiation if it's
successful would be July 1st 24th
following
yes okay anyone
else Senator Bray and then Mr Martin um
just a comment on Senator sus um that
certainly I would be willing to work
with her on doing something that would
make this effective uh sooner if uh the
commission wanted to recommend it uh so
that it could be uh available for June
of next
year but no no guarantees of
course Mr
martinz thank you madam chair I'd like
to speak on the motion itself and uh
with all respect to to the Senate to The
Honorable Senator I do not believe that
we need a legislative bill or law to
tell us to Collective bargain anything
for now I would say that in my mind the
Deferred Compensation wheel it's already
invented we have a Deferred Compensation
Plan that most people a lot of people
participate including myself so I would
think that this is
not anything in the Realms of what we
need to do which is
this we had a cost of living adjustment
since
1967 when the retirement system came
together and is stayed in place until
2011 it was always the intent of the
legislature that we have a vital cost of
living adjustment so much so that in
1983 we put together a cola account
which was not perfect it had some IRS
implication it was not correct
but like with any vehicle that is not
working well you either fix it or
replace it but in this case the state
decided to stop driving altogether we
cannot have a retirement system where
the benefits will water and wash away
over the years because of
inflation the thing that would make
sense is to return to what was meant to
be and have a defined benefit
Cola spelled out in RSA in our
retirement system as we
did a defined a Deferred Compensation
Plan that will just replace what we have
or duplicates that will
only changes by having perhaps a
employer Buy in I do not think that is
what we
intend to do I would think that this
would only
obfuscate the Mission and the goal to
get cola back and fix it as it was
always intended to
be um so in because of that you know I
do not support this this motion I think
we need to stick to stick with working
on a cost of leing adjustment as a
defined benefit in RSA through New
Hampshire retirement system thank you
and I'll you thank you Senator BR uh
just responding a little bit to uh uh
gentleman 's comments um as to being
able to do it now if you read U 101 B7
and 101b colon 8 uh those Provisions
there would prevent you for state
employees from doing this um so you
right now uh the local employees because
they have done different things uh are
able to do this whether they're doing it
through a deferred Benefit Plan or
whatever uh they have taken care of that
uh but right now for a state employee
you cannot do it okay you cannot
dedicate the funds you can't spend the
funds uh and and deposited into that
because of uh 101 B7 and 101 B8 uh and I
you know
although you know I would like to see
something done for for the group one
employees uh this is is the one thing
that that that I think that we can do
for group one um because this retirement
commission is uh is not limited just to
group two um and the discussion of any
Cola um if there's a proposal in front
of us we we'll vote on that certainly
separately from from this proposal thank
you yes Mr R thank you madam chair um I
would uh also vote against this proposal
for a few reasons first um I would like
to uh address Senator Gray's uh comments
that uh we're not doing anything for the
group one folks and um while I support
uh the cost of living adjustment
conversation for all I think that's a
part of a bigger uh discussion that
needs to continue um and I understand
we're limited on time with this
commission but uh if there's an
extension of the commission to discuss
that issue I would love to be a part of
those
conversations um but we also need to
remember that the the legislature just
passed um the the Social Security offset
bill which was a pretty significant um
uh Victory I think for for both the
state and group one um last session and
this was uh part of the problem that we
were trying to fix was this um inequity
on the uh group two uh or perceived
inequity I should say um so
so with that I think Senator Gray's
proposal while I think it comes from a
good place um I I believe that it's a
solution in search of a problem um I've
not heard this as an
overwhelming uh issue with with group
one employees uh I represent uh a few
group one employees in in my
organization and this has never come up
um so with that I would um agree with M
Martins and I would vote against this
any else I'd like to say that simply by
removing the prohibition on such a uh
contribution by the employ employer to
their to the existing plan that many
employees are already contributing to
this is doesn't say that it has to be
negotiated or how it just says that if
the employees choose to ask for it it's
not illeg
legal and so I I'm going to be
supporting it on that
ground anyone
else all right
um those in favor of Senator Gray's
proposal uh please raise your
hand all right those
opposed ah the motion fails on a tie so
the commission is not going to recommend
this anyone
else all
right in that case I think the immediate
work of this commission is done we need
to keep talking to each other because
some of the issues that were brought up
have not reached a
solution possi living increases for one
we have recommended I believe four
pieces of
legislation um the earlier vesting
mandatory over only three and and um and
this
plan uh but we have not come up with
anything on the cost of living issue
because we've been unable to reach any
kind of even a rough agreement so we
need to keep talking to each other to
resolve that issue
point of inquiry Madam chair uh in that
list do we have an item
for employees that already vested and
left service and came back in a
part-time position that would allow them
to contribute to the retirement system
because they already
vested um I believe that's if a person
comes back um
I'm not miss Mr Carlin could you explain
that issue to us I think you you're more
familiar with the the details I
am thank you uh Madam chair for calling
me up can I just clarify are you talking
about a vested um member who ceases
employment and then comes back in a
part-time capacity yes okay so that that
there's no law against that happening
but the person wouldn't acrew any
service for that part-time right now so
I thought the question was creating a
changing the law so that they could
continue crew nhrs membership credit for
that time continue to pay into the fund
yeah they don't part-time person doesn't
pay into the retirement system correct
correct correct yeah and the employer
doesn't pay anything on no no part-time
employee is none of their salar is
contributed to nhrs the employer doesn't
pay anything on any of them now
currently for all groups okay there
there is definitions of um full-time
permanent positions both um somewhat in
the statute and also in our
administrative rules to Define
full-time no part-time person
contributes to the retirement system
whether they're previously employed or
not so and I think that's a bigger issue
it came up when Mr Fuller was talking
about part-time
people so Madam chair if I may I think
I'm in favor of obviously to have
part-time contribute to the retirement
system but I'll say this is be a good
place to start with an employee who's
already part of the system who's already
vested and would be an added value to
the system to have further contributions
that could be used for Investments and
build that pension so I I would uh
respectfully ask to uh include that in
one of the uh items on this commission
to look at as we go forward to allow
full-time allow vested workers who
retire come back
part-time not retired come back
part-time to contribute to the
retirement system okay we will and and
build a
retirement I beg your pardon did someone
someone wish to
speak okay all right so we'll make that
a comment that to look into part-time
contributions bested well we you will
have to look at the overall part-time
issue I mean I don't think that that
specific case would be common enough to
be worth doing the proper analysis for
it but looking at part-time employees
yes we've got a lot of them Madam chair
if I may follow up on bit uh we do have
a lot of workers that are returning that
return and they
have vested uh not just group one one
teachers uh and it might be group two as
well I don't know but would be nice to
look into it if if we may right thank
you all
right all right if no one else has any
Senator Bradley um I think either
Senator gray or I will probably file a
Minority Report um you know in support
of the
15-year um proposal thank you that was I
was just getting into the committee
report oh okay then I'll stop there okay
we Mr R and I will be working on the
committee report and send it out
including your Minority Report as
received and then we will send it out to
the commission for your approval
so that it can be submitted by December
1st and I have another point of inquir
Madam yes M Mar um did you say this
report will include a study for the cost
of living
adjustment that's one of the issues that
we need to keep in mind because we have
not reached a conclusion in this group
yes there there's a couple of
open-ended items that we need need to
keep thinking about and talking to each
other about because as you've noticed
we' that even this small group has some
very different opinions on different
things so we need to talk to each other
and find out what's important and what
needs to be done and cost of living
increases are one of them okay I must
say it's been a pleasure working with
you all if else Senator Bradley um I was
going to say before but I'll say it now
we're at the end um thank you madam
chair I think you've done a unbelievable
job of uh you know pulling this together
and uh this is one step in the process
but you deserve a lot of kudos for um
all the work that youve put in so thank
you thank you all right thank you all we
are
adjourned
that